folks walking towards power clutching
the folder with the long list of issues
this new leader needs to tackle
the candidate selected as the
parliament's nominee for the position of
first minister is Hamza Yusuf
it was a day of procedure and formality
before the victory speech from Scotland
sit first Minister but the first of
Muslim faith there was a time not all
that long ago when I fell I simply did
not belong here in Scotland
to grow to go from there to now leading
the government as Scotland's sixth first
Minister I hope sends a strong message
to every single person out there who
feels that they don't belong
earlier after 3 000 days at the top an
exit moment Nicholas sturgeon formally
resigning in this letter to the king
how are you feeling
but absolutely convinced I've done the
right thing and I'm looking forward to
the future
as he attempts to reunite the SNP what
were his plans for his main rival Kate
Forbes I've always been I've already
spoke to kids from yesterday I
absolutely want Kate Forbes to be part
of the government and what has been an
explosive twist it now transpires miss
Forbes was offered the cabinet demotion
from Finance secretary to the rural
Affairs brief something she swiftly
rejected and this creates a problem for
the new first Minister here at Hollywood
who knows that tens of thousands of SNP
supporters voted for that position of
change they thought continuity wouldn't
cut it
posing with Proud Family before a phone
conversation with the Prime Minister
when it's understood Independence was
front and center Conor Gillis Sky News
Hollywood